Shure:  嗯呐嗯呐
Shure: Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Shure:  都退完了然后也没花手续费什么的
Shure: Everything is refunded, and there were no fees.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey,
Katrina: 卧槽
Katrina: Whoa,
Katrina:  手抖
Katrina: my hand shook.
Shure:  喝多了手抖了开始
Shure: Drank too much, my hand's shaking.
Shure:  你他妈给他画一个
Shure: Draw something for him.
Katrina: 尾巴
Katrina: A tail.
Katrina:  别瞎想
Katrina: Don't overthink it.
Shure:  我以为是
Shure: I thought it was...
Katrina:  你以为你以为
Katrina: You thought, you thought.
Shure:  尾巴都长一撮毛了
Shure: The tail has a tuft of hair.
Katrina:  给他配一个英文的
Katrina: Give him an English name.
Katrina:  呦呼就这样
Katrina: Woo-hoo, just like that.
Shure: 我们我们给他起个名吧
Shure: Let's give him a name.
Shure:  叫
Shure: Call him...
Katrina:  线条小狗
Katrina: Line Dog.
Katrina:  创作日期
Katrina: Creation date.
Katrina:  创作大师亲笔签名Lyx
Katrina: Signed by the master artist, Lyx.
Shure:  你好摄像头
Shure: Hello, camera.
Katrina:  这画的Hellokitty有点抽象
Katrina: This Hello Kitty drawing is a bit abstract.
Katrina:  这谁画的
Katrina: Who drew this?
Katrina: a little bit ugly
Katrina: A little bit ugly.
Shure:  你真的你真的
Shure: You really, you really...
Shure:  你现在腿跟腿跟头发一个色的
Shure: Your legs and hair are the same color now.
Katrina:  我居然
Katrina: I actually...
Katrina:  我居然上脸哎
Katrina: I actually got a face flush.
Shure: 真的上脸
Shure: Really flushed.
Katrina: 以后就跟领导说酒精过敏
Katrina: I'll just tell the boss I'm allergic to alcohol.
Katrina: 喝不了酒
Katrina: Can't drink.
Shure: 啊酒精过敏喝不了酒
Shure: Ah, allergic to alcohol, can't drink.
Katrina:  啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  你特像那小学生
Katrina: You look like a school kid.
Katrina:  我们班上的男生
Katrina: The boys in my class.
Shure: 啊酒精过敏喝不了酒
Shure: Ah, allergic to alcohol, can't drink.
Katrina: 打扫卫生
Katrina: Cleaning up.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 我们上去打扫卫生去
Shure: Let's go clean up.
Shure:  快把你的斧根喝掉
Shure: Hurry up and finish your drink.
Katrina:  好
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina:  喝完就打一套醉拳
Katrina: I'll do some Drunken Fist after drinking.
Shure:  什么打电话去
Shure: What? Call someone?
Katrina: 打一套醉拳呐
Katrina: Do some Drunken Fist!
Katrina:  啊被倒掉了
Katrina: Ah, it's been spilled!
Shure:  完了你的斧根被倒掉了
Shure: Oh no, your drink got spilled.
Shure:  也没有斧了
Shure: And there's no more.
Katrina:  太好了哇菜刀
Katrina: Great, oh a kitchen knife!
Katrina: 菜刀怎么会出现在这里
Katrina: Why is there a kitchen knife here?
Katrina:  给你舞一个
Katrina: Let me dance with it.
Katrina:  自己刀哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Dance with my own knife, hahaha.
Katrina:  这油倒哪呢
Katrina: Where should I pour this oil?
Tasha: 那
Tasha: There.
Shure:  为什么拿他晒
Shure: Why use that for sunbathing?
Shure:  给你倒的酒你没有喝
Shure: The drink I poured for you, you didn't drink it.
Tasha: 我喝了
Tasha: I did drink it.
Shure:  喝了那一捏捏算啊
Shure: Just a little sip doesn't count.
Katrina: 一人我饮酒醉
Katrina: Drinking alone makes me drunk.
Tasha: 你好会扭哦
Tasha: You dance so well.
Katrina:  倒倒倒哪来的
Katrina: Pour, pour, where did this come from?
Shure:  我来倒吧
Shure: Let me pour it.
Shure:  我来倒我来倒
Shure: Let me pour it, let me pour it.
Katrina:  倒麻酱里
Katrina: Pour it into the sesame paste.
Tasha: 对先倒到这吧
Tasha: Yeah, pour it here first.
Katrina:  小时候我给老鼠做老鼠药就这样
Katrina: When I was a kid, I made rat poison like this.
Shure:  还做这个呢
Shure: You made that too?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Katrina: 风油精花露水
Katrina: Essential balm and floral water.
Katrina:  加一点好吃的饼干
Katrina: Add some tasty cookies.
Katrina:  哎我看有没有那个塑料袋
Katrina: Let me see if there are any plastic bags.
Katrina:  我们直接扔了
Katrina: We'll just throw it away.
Shure:  你觉得我
Shure: Do you think I...
Shure:  我明天这瓶我觉得就可以喝完了
Shure: I think I can finish this bottle by tomorrow.
Katrina:  哈哈哈再说你你就这样拿
Katrina: Hahaha, you just hold it like this.
Katrina:  我们给你拍个海报
Katrina: We'll take a poster of you.
Katrina:  就那天迎宾的时候
Katrina: Like when we welcomed guests that day.
Katrina:  易拉罐呵呵呵呵
Katrina: Soda can, hahaha
Jake: 确实
Jake: Definitely
Shure:  哎呀
Shure: Oh man
Katrina: 咱不是有几个盒马的袋子吗
Katrina: Don't we have a few Hema bags?
Katrina:  噢我有泸溪河的
Katrina: Oh, I have some Luxihe bags
Katrina: 泸溪河的袋子
Katrina: Luxihe bags
Shure:  泸溪河
Shure: Luxihe
Jake: 来您您来一起加加油吧
Jake: Come on, let's cheer together
Jake: 要不
Jake: Or...
Katrina:  这谁的养乐多呀
Katrina: Whose Yakult is this?
Alice:哦他刚开的
Alice: Oh, he just opened it
Tasha: 我教您
Tasha: Let me show you
Tasha: 您就把这个
Tasha: You just take this
Shure: 我不听加油加油加油我不听
Shure: I don't want to hear it, cheer, cheer, cheer, I don't want to hear
Shure:  加油加油哈哈哈
Shure: Cheer, cheer, hahaha
Katrina: 放进来吧
Katrina: Put it in
Katrina:  你今天晚上任务是负责把
Katrina: Your task tonight is to...
Katrina:  yes OK
Katrina: Yes, OK
Katrina:  学会明天教我们
Katrina: Learn it and teach us tomorrow
Shure:  我我我今天晚上负负责喝的死死的
Shure: I-I-I tonight am r-responsible for drinking till I drop
Shure:  然后睡觉
Shure: Then sleep
Katrina:  Lucy和儿子太像了呀
Katrina: Lucia looks so much like her son
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no
Shure:  酒精大学四年怎么过来的
Shure: How did I survive four years of college with alcohol?
Katrina:  哎苦学生
Katrina: Oh, poor student
Katrina:  嘘又被我撞到了
Katrina: Shh, I bumped into it again
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈嘘
Katrina: Hahaha, shh
Katrina:  大学四年都干什么啊
Katrina: What did you do for four years in college?
Katrina:  忘了感觉保研之后才真正大学生活
Katrina: I forgot, it feels like the real college life started after getting a guaranteed admission
Katrina:  但是我感觉我也没有那种特别
Katrina: But I don't feel like I studied particularly hard
Katrina:  就是学的特别吓人的那种
Katrina: Like those who study intensely during finals week
Katrina:  就是期末周去那种
Katrina: Mainly because our class...
Katrina:  主要我们班
Katrina: Our class has a high guarantee rate
Katrina:  我们班保研率很高保40%
Katrina: 40% guaranteed admission rate
Katrina:  然后运气特别好
Katrina: And we were really lucky
Katrina:  然后一般就是我们年级这个实验班
Katrina: Generally, our experimental class in our year...
Katrina:  他是需要竞争
Katrina: You need to compete
Katrina:  大一分流的时候竞争进去
Katrina: Compete during the freshman year division
Katrina:  然后我们那一年
Katrina: And then our year...
Katrina:  我们那一年没人报你知道吗
Katrina: That year, no one applied, did you know?
Katrina:  然后我绩点那么低我都进了
Katrina: And then my GPA was so low but I still got in.
Katrina:  然后我就保研了
Katrina: And then I got a guaranteed spot for grad school.
Alice: 这俩是谁的
Alice: Whose are these two?
Alice:还喝吗
Alice: Are you still drinking?
Katrina:  我人生很搞笑的我感觉
Katrina: My life is so funny, I feel.
Shure:  东北孩子都会唱刀郎
Shure: Kids from the Northeast all sing Dao Lang songs.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Katrina: 呀呀呀还有没有
Katrina: Hey hey hey, is there any more?
Shure:  你好恶心
Shure: You're so disgusting.
Katrina:  麻酱no
Katrina: Sesame sauce no.
Shure:  麻酱no
Shure: Sesame sauce no.
Katrina: yes no
Katrina: Yes no.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Katrina:  狂加醋
Katrina: Add lots of vinegar.
Jake: 嘿卢亚呢
Jake: Hey, where's Luya?
Shure:  卢亚已经睡着了吧
Shure: Luya might be asleep already.
Shure:  可能
Shure: Maybe.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:卢亚带个眼镜呗
Jake: Luya should wear glasses.
Shure:  他喝了一碗
Shure: He drank a bowl.
Jake: 一碗
Jake: A bowl.
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: It's over.
Shure:  我们要不晚上再来一局吧
Shure: How about we have another round tonight?
Katrina:  哈哈晚上再来一局
Katrina: Haha, another round tonight.
Katrina:  就直接给你掏心掏肺讲故事了
Katrina: I'll just pour my heart out and tell you stories.
Shure:  哈哈哈我就要听掏心掏肺讲故事哎
Shure: Hahaha, I just want to hear heartfelt stories.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Shure:  其实其实酒桌上掏心掏肺讲故事
Shure: Actually, actually, heartfelt stories at the table.
Shure:  第二天第二另另外几个人都记不住
Shure: The next day, no one remembers.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Shure:  哈哈哈掏心掏肺讲完了你你很爽
Shure: Hahaha, after pouring your heart out, you feel great.
Shure:  然后其他人也很爽
Shure: And everyone else feels great too.
Shure:  但是大家都记不住这个事
Shure: But no one remembers it.
Shure:  情就很很很爽
Shure: The feeling is just great.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Katrina:  对爽了就行
Katrina: Yeah, as long as it feels great.
Shure:  这大家只走一个过程
Shure: Everyone just goes through the process.
Katrina:  真好呀主要我当时我舍友都特别乖
Katrina: It's so nice. Mainly, my roommates were all very obedient back then.
Katrina:  没人提议说去酒吧
Katrina: No one suggested going to the bar.
Shure:  也不一定非去酒吧呀
Shure: You don't necessarily have to go to a bar.
Katrina:  他们不喝
Katrina: They don't drink.
Katrina:  哎呦喝一瓶RIO就倒了
Katrina: Oh my, they get knocked out after one bottle of RIO.
Katrina: crazy
Katrina: Crazy.
Jake: 这边都不够
Jake: This isn't enough.
Jake: 要不带点下去洗
Jake: How about we take some downstairs to wash?
Jake: 再带一个吧
Jake: Let's bring another one.
Jake: 碗下去洗吧要不
Jake: How about we take the bowls downstairs to wash?
Jake: 这边够了
Jake: This is enough here.
Shure:  加油加油加油加油加
Shure: Keep going, keep going, keep going, keep going.
Katrina: 你跳那个
Katrina: You dance that.
Katrina:  cheer baby
Katrina: Cheer baby.
Katrina: 你听过twice那歌没有
Katrina: Have you heard that song by TWICE?
Choiszt: 呃等会你先别扔
Choiszt: Uh, wait, don't throw it yet.
Katrina: twice的那个歌
Katrina: The song by TWICE.
Katrina:  他有一首歌叫cheer cheer up就很元气
Katrina: They have a song called "Cheer Up," it's so energetic.
Katrina:  什么cheerbaby
Katrina: What cheer baby?
Katrina:  就是他们在干家务的时候
Katrina: It's like when they're doing housework.
Katrina:  你就在旁边cheer
Katrina: You cheer beside them.
Katrina:  babycheer
Katrina: Baby cheer.
Katrina:  baby还会跳
Katrina: Baby can even dance.
Shure:  啊你也会跳这个是吗
Shure: Ah, you can dance to this too?
Katrina:  会啊高中的时候不是可流行的吗
Katrina: Yeah, it was so popular in high school, wasn't it?
Shure:  杨老板会跳这个吗
Shure: Can Jake dance this?
Jake: 啥呀
Jake: What?
Katrina:  教他一些课业之后
Katrina: After teaching him some lessons.
Shure: 好东西
Shure: Good stuff.
Jake: 哦会跳这个
Jake: Oh, I can dance to this.
Jake: 因为我我以前
Jake: Because I, I used to...
Katrina: 也年轻过
Katrina: Was young too.
Jake: 那个房东的小孩
Jake: The landlord's kid.
Jake: 就天天在我面前秀这个
Jake: Would show off this dance in front of me every day.
Tasha: 这个水是用这个是洗不掉的
Tasha: This water can't wash this off.
Jake: 那用什么
Jake: Then what should we use?
Shure:  看杨老板也不一般
Shure: Look, Jake isn't ordinary either.
Katrina:  也年轻过
Katrina: Was young too.
Shure:  也年轻过
Shure: Was young too.
Shure:  谁没年轻过呢是吧
Shure: Who hasn't been young, right?
Choiszt: 你们这些袋要扔吗现在
Choiszt: Are you going to throw these bags away now?
Tasha: 要吗
Tasha: Do you want to?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:要扔
Jake: Gotta throw it.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Choiszt: 带个手套吧
Choiszt: Put on some gloves.
Tasha: 哦我还以为你要把它装进来
Tasha: Oh, I thought you were going to pack it in.
Katrina:  你看我站在这里
Katrina: Look, I'm standing here.
Katrina:  其实我已经走了一会
Katrina: Actually, I've been walking for a while.
Katrina: 你看我站在这里
Katrina: Look, I'm standing here.
Katrina:  其实我已经走了一会
Katrina: Actually, I've been walking for a while.
Shure:  哲学你懂吗
Shure: Do you understand philosophy?
Shure:  他虽然就是形态站在这
Shure: Although he's physically standing here...
Shure:  但是意识已经走了
Shure: His mind has already wandered off.
Nicous: 绝对有点喝多了
Nicous: He's definitely had a bit too much to drink.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 不要紧
Shure: It's alright.
Tasha: 这还有个男呃好吧他走了
Tasha: There's a guy... Oh well, he's gone.
Katrina:  酒量测试开始
Katrina: Drinking test starts now.
Katrina:  这怎么洗呢
Katrina: How do we wash this?
Katrina:  能拿厨房湿巾吗
Katrina: Can we use kitchen wipes?
Katrina: 我也拿一个湿巾
Katrina: I'll grab a wipe too.
Tasha: 就就在这洗吧
Tasha: Just wash it here.
Tasha: 你可以换一张抹布了
Tasha: You can switch to a new cloth.
Lucia: 更方便洗一些
Lucia: It's easier to clean that way.
Jake:还还能用
Jake: It can still be used.
Lucia: 这能先擦一遍吗
Lucia: Can we wipe it down first?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This.
Tasha: 这个不用待会直接洗洁精洗就行了
Tasha: No need, just wash it with dish soap later.
Lucia: 啊那也行
Lucia: Ah, that works too.
Lucia: 感觉里面很多渣
Lucia: Feels like there's a lot of residue inside.
Lucia: 有的把它先弄出来
Lucia: Let's get it out first.
Lucia: 刚那个不是有点
Lucia: Wasn't there some...
Lucia: 稍微有点
Lucia: A bit clogged.
Lucia: 那个啥有点堵
Tasha: 喝一口啊
Tasha: Have a sip.
Tasha: 这汤好鲜美啊
Tasha: This soup is so fresh and delicious.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 你确实
Tasha: You sure?
Shure:  我给你们打call
Shure: I'll cheer for you guys.
Jake: 你说的真的
Jake: You really mean it.
Jake: 那就是真的
Jake: Then it's real.
Katrina:  你喝什么呢
Katrina: What are you drinking?
Shure:  啤啤酒
Shure: Beer.
Shure:  尝一尝吧
Shure: Try it.
Katrina:  不要了
Katrina: No, thanks.
Katrina:  再那个我都害怕
Katrina: I'm scared of drinking more.
Shure:  你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure:  哈哈他妈的
Shure: Haha, damn it.
Katrina: 当心
Katrina: Be careful.
Tasha: 我帮你扔掉
Tasha: I'll throw it away for you.
Jake: 谢谢您哎
Jake: Thank you.
Alice: 没事这可能是他的陈年污渍
Alice: No problem, it might be an old stain.
Lucia: 对擦了擦感觉掉不了
Lucia: Yeah, it feels like it won't come off.
Lucia: 不管他那个了
Lucia: Let's not worry about it.
Tasha: 你看还好买了一包吧
Tasha: Good thing we bought a pack.
Tasha: 这个锅原来在二楼吗
Tasha: Was this pot originally on the second floor?
Lucia: 这个这个锅吗
Lucia: This pot?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Lucia: 我也我也不太确定
Lucia: I'm not really sure.
Lucia: 我也不太确定
Alice: 这是我们的还是这的
Alice: Is it ours or does it belong here?
Lucia: 这些锅应该都是这儿的
Lucia: These pots should all belong here.
Alice: 那放二楼吧
Alice: Then let's put it on the second floor.
Shure: 你不要瞎说好吗
Shure: Can you stop talking nonsense?
Shure:  我觉得
Shure: I think...
Shure:  是时候拿出吉他了
Shure: It's time to bring out the guitar.
Alice: 来防一下锅
Alice: Let's put the pot away.
Shure:  找草坪干嘛
Shure: Why are you looking for grass?
Tasha: 嗯放这吧
Tasha: Hmm, let's put it here.
Lucia: 那我把这个也放进去吧
Lucia: Then I'll put this in too.
Lucia: 给你增加一点工作量
Lucia: Adding some more work for you.
Shure:  洗手间
Shure: Bathroom.
Shure:  帅老师不喜欢回归大自然吗
Shure: Doesn't Mr. Choiszt like returning to nature?
Alice: 这谁的呀
Alice: Whose is this?
Lucia: 那个板可以拿来立着
Lucia: That board can be stood up.
Tasha: 这个是我的
Tasha: This one's mine.
Tasha: 但是我没喝完嘛
Tasha: But I haven't finished it.
Alice: 那我给你留这了啊
Alice: Then I'll leave it here for you.
Tasha: 好行
Tasha: Alright, thanks.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
Shure:  你喝吗啊
Shure: Are you drinking?
Shure:  你喝吗
Tasha: 我喝呢
Tasha: I'm drinking.
Shure: 你真喝吗
Shure: Really?
Tasha: 真喝呢
Tasha: Really drinking.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 你喝一杯应该没关系吧
Tasha: You should be fine with one drink, right?
Shure:  喝一杯他
Shure: Just one drink.
Shure:  他毫无关系
Shure: It doesn't matter at all.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice: 醋放下边
Alice: Put the vinegar down there.
Shure:  我觉得就要给AI加一些不可控因素
Shure: I think we need to add some uncontrollable factors to the AI.
Tasha: 行啊
Tasha: Sure.
Shure:  没事这这这柜里还有3瓶呢
Shure: It's fine, we still have 3 bottles in the cabinet.
Katrina:  呀我手机放哪了
Katrina: Where did I put my phone?
Lucia: 啊对不起对不起啊
Lucia: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 刚那个有点使劲好像水崩起来了
Lucia: I think I used too much force and the water splashed.
Tasha: 买一个小碗洗碗机吧
Tasha: Let's buy a small dishwasher.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 我们有硕
Jake: We have Shure.
Alice: 还有垃圾吗
Alice: Any more trash?
Tasha: 硕硕
Tasha: Shure.
Jake: 来一轮
Jake: Let's have a round.
Alice: 没了
Alice: No more.
Lucia: 这个可以当垃圾袋用
Lucia: We can use this as a trash bag.
Lucia: 因为里面扔了很多
Lucia: Because there’s a lot inside.
Shure:  what's up bro
Shure: What's up, bro?
Tasha: 让你买个洗碗机
Tasha: Buy a dishwasher.
Jake:让你当个洗碗机
Jake: Be a dishwasher.
Tasha: 让你当个洗碗机
Tasha: Be a dishwasher.
Shure:  让我买个洗碗机
Shure: Buy a dishwasher.
Jake: 买个是难
Jake: Buying is hard.
Tasha: 让你当一个洗碗机
Tasha: Be a dishwasher.
Shure: 什么买个洗碗机
Shure: Buy a dishwasher.
Jake: 当个洗碗机
Jake: Be a dishwasher.
Shure:  我靠买个洗碗机
Shure: Damn, buy a dishwasher.
Shure:  真的吗bro
Shure: Really, bro?
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Tasha: 堵住了你有没有发现需要您清理
Tasha: It's clogged, did you notice it needs cleaning?
Tasha: 这筷子洗的
Tasha: These chopsticks are washed...
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha: 真有水平
Tasha: Really skillful.
Shure:  跟洗跟没洗的一样
Shure: It's like they weren't washed at all.
Tasha: 你看他这个筷子洗的
Tasha: Look at how these chopsticks are washed.
Tasha: 洗成两坨了
Tasha: They're washed into two lumps.
Shure:  哎呦卧槽
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake: 跟没洗的一样
Jake: Just like they weren't washed.
Tasha: 我真受不了了
Tasha: I really can't stand this.
Shure:  一看就是在家
Shure: Clearly, someone was at home.
Shure:  一天天娇生惯养的孩子们
Shure: Spoiled kids, day in and day out.
Jake: 可拉倒吧
Jake: Oh, come on.
Jake: 谁在家呢
Jake: Who was at home?
Shure:  请问在在Singapore
Shure: May I ask, in Singapore?
Shure:  娇生惯养的孩子
Shure: Spoiled kids.
Jake: 那也没在在Singapore也不在家待着
Jake: Even in Singapore, they weren't at home.
Shure:  哎我搅一会吧
Shure: Let me stir it for a while.
Shure:  然后先让他水流下去
Shure: Then let the water flow first.
Jake:我这先搁哪呢
Jake: Where should I put this for now?
Shure:  你随便搁哪都行
Shure: You can put it anywhere.
Shure:  然后我搅一会就行
Shure: I'll stir it for a while.
Shure:  你别搁搁地漏上就行
Shure: Just don't put it on the drain.
Jake: 我先去洗洗手去
Jake: I'll go wash my hands first.
Shure:  哎愁死了
Shure: This is stressing me out.
Lucia: 这这袋子先放这扔垃圾了
Lucia: This bag, put it here for the trash.
Lucia: 扔满了再拿下去
Lucia: When it's full, take it down.
Shure:  哎呦我搅一下
Shure: Oh, let me stir it.
Tasha: 哈哈哈洗碗机成功
Tasha: Hahaha, dishwasher success.
Shure:  ai看到了吗
Shure: Did you see it?
Shure:  就是人类搅一圈之后
Shure: After humans stir for a bit,
Shure:  手上会有这么多油
Shure: There's so much oil on their hands.
Shure:  你记住了吗
Shure: Did you remember?
Lucia: 你记住了吗
Lucia: Did you remember?
Shure:  侮辱杨老板的数据石吧
Shure: Insulting Jake's data.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha: 这越洗越油
Tasha: The more you wash, the oilier it gets.
Tasha: 不要用另一只手摸他了
Tasha: Don't touch it with the other hand.
Lucia: 你拿这个擦一擦
Lucia: Use this to wipe it.
Lucia: 可以去油应该
Lucia: It should remove the oil.
Shure:  这样
Shure: Like this.
Alice: 这洗好了吗
Alice: Is this washed?
Tasha: 这还要再冲一遍呢
Tasha: It needs another rinse.
Tasha: 这只用洗洁精抹了一遍
Tasha: I just wiped it once with dish soap.
Alice: 是呢
Alice: Right.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 刚洗的手
Alice: Just washed my hands.
Shure: 对然后随便找个袋
Shure: Yeah, then just find any bag.
Shure: 然后然后然后我倒下去
Shure: And then, and then, I'll pour it in.
Tasha: 你经常干这个活啊
Tasha: You do this often, huh?
Tasha: 把里面的渣渣能不能捞出来
Tasha: Can you scoop out the residue inside?
Shure:  一遍一遍冲进去就好了
Shure: Just rinse it in and out a few times.
Tasha: 倒也不用这么干净吧我觉得
Tasha: I don't think it needs to be that clean.
Shure:  咱过四五天呢哥
Shure: We're doing this for four or five days, bro.
Tasha: 要不以后别用楼上的厨房了哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Maybe we shouldn't use the upstairs kitchen anymore, haha.
Shure: 要不以后别用厨房了都点外卖了
Shure: Maybe we should just stop using the kitchen and order takeout.
Shure: 咱买一次性的锅
Shure: Let's buy disposable pots.
Tasha: 还有一次性的锅这种说
Tasha: They have disposable pots?
Shure:  有那锡纸锅两块钱一个哈哈
Shure: Yeah, those foil pots, two bucks each, haha.
Shure:  卧槽真的
Shure: Seriously.
Tasha: 你就是专业干这个的呀
Tasha: You're really a pro at this.
Tasha: 怪不得喊你来当洗碗机呢
Tasha: No wonder they asked you to be the dishwasher.
Lucia: 这边我觉得还是
Lucia: Over here, I think...
Tasha: 需要帮忙吗
Tasha: Need some help?
Lucia: 等过会擦吧
Lucia: We'll wipe it later.
Lucia: 这太高了吧
Lucia: This is too high.
Lucia: 放下来一点
Lucia: Lower it a bit.
Tasha: 这个还要再冲一遍了
Tasha: This needs another rinse.
Alice: 你手串是开过光的吗
Alice: Is your bracelet blessed?
Alice: 你那手串开过光吗
Shure:  没有女朋友随便送我的
Shure: No, my girlfriend randomly gave it to me.
Tasha: 肯定是他不要的哈哈哈
Tasha: Probably something she didn't want, haha.
Shure:  我就你会说话是不是
Shure: Are you always this good at talking?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure:  你信不信我这这盘子抡你脑袋上
Shure: Do you believe I'll hit you with this plate?
Tasha: 你说随便送东西的
Tasha: You said it was randomly given.
Tasha: 肯定是她淘汰下来的货
Tasha: Must be something she didn't want.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  因为我平时平时穿粉色衣服多
Shure: Because I usually wear pink clothes.
Shure:  然后送我一个粉色手串
Shure: So she gave me a pink bracelet.
Tasha: 哦你早说嘛
Tasha: Oh, you should've said that earlier.
Tasha: 是她特地送给你的不就行了
Tasha: If she specifically gave it to you, it's fine.
Tasha: 你为什么说是随便送给你的
Tasha: Why did you say she gave it to you casually?
Shure:  我他妈
Shure: What the hell...
Alice: 要轻描淡写过去这个话题哈哈哈
Alice: Just gloss over this topic, haha.
Tasha: 然后还说要打我
Tasha: And then she said she was going to hit me.
Alice: 哎我手机呢
Alice: Hey, where's my phone?
Lucia: 站一会没找到什么可以擦的东西
Lucia: I stood here for a while but couldn't find anything to wipe with.
Shure:  把杯子先都刷出来了
Shure: Let's wash all the cups first.
Shure:  因为杯子啊
Shure: Because cups...
Shure:  啊对于喝酒
Shure: are really important for drinking, so we need to wash them all.
Shure:  来说很重要所以要都刷出来
Shure: That's why we need to wash them all.
Lucia: 这没杯子吗
Lucia: Are there no cups?
Shure:  这本来就有杯子
Shure: There were cups originally.
Shure:  咱们都使完了你知道吗
Shure: We used them all, you know?
Lucia: 不是我是说
Lucia: No, I mean...
Lucia: 就是我没看到有刷完需要擦的杯子
Lucia: I didn't see any cups that need wiping after washing.
Lucia: 就是你这不是正刷着吗
Lucia: I mean, aren't you still washing them?
Shure:  行了我刷了我刷了
Shure: Alright, alright, I'll wash them.
Shure:  哎呦呦呦呦
Shure: Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Shure:  帮我拿点谢谢
Shure: Help me out, thanks.
Shure:  愁死了
Shure: This is stressing me out.
Shure:  什什么喝完酒还要刷杯子呀
Shure: Why do we have to wash cups after drinking?
Shure:  卧槽这是
Shure: Damn, this is...
Alice: 啊这还有俩锅
Alice: Oh, there are still two pots.
Shure:  杨老板给我结double工资
Shure: Jake should pay me double.
Shure:  不然话我不干了杨老板
Shure: Otherwise, I won't do it, Jake.
Tasha: 这可不是你能决定的
Tasha: That's not for you to decide.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 我把这碗拿下拿到楼下刷一下算了
Lucia: I'll take this bowl downstairs to wash it.
Shure:  这碗不是刷完的吗
Shure: Wasn't this bowl already washed?
Lucia: 不是要再涮一遍吗
Lucia: Doesn't it need another rinse?
Tasha: 再冲一遍就行了
Tasha: Just rinse it again and it's fine.
Shure: 你哎
Shure: You...
Lucia: 不是有
Lucia: Isn't there...
Tasha: 拿下去
Tasha: Take it down.
Shure:  哎再再给我用一下
Shure: Hey, let me use it again.
Tasha: 旁边还有洗洁精吗
Tasha: Is there any dish soap left?
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Shure:  不要了
Shure: No more.
Alice: 有点难受了
Alice: I'm feeling a bit uncomfortable.
Alice: 热热的
Alice: It's hot.
Tasha: 不知道明天干嘛
Tasha: I don't know what to do tomorrow.
Katrina:  明天干嘛
Katrina: What to do tomorrow?
Katrina:  我要写小本了
Katrina: I need to write my little notebook.
Katrina:  to do list
Katrina: To-do list.
Alice: 我能不能看着搓啊
Alice: Can I just watch others play?
Tasha: 看着搓什么意思
Tasha: What do you mean by watching others play?
Alice:就看着别人打
Alice: Just watch them play.
Tasha: 也可以呢
Tasha: That works too.
Alice:凑够四个人很简单的吧应该吧
Alice: It should be easy to gather four people, right?
Tasha: 应该吧
Tasha: Should be.
Tasha: 不知道谁打呢
Tasha: Don't know who's playing.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm, hmm.
Katrina:  现在是期中考试月
Katrina: It's midterm exam month now.
Shure:  你们还有期中考试吗
Shure: You guys still have midterms?
Katrina:  没有看我学弟他们发的朋友圈
Katrina: No, I just saw my juniors posting on social media.
Katrina:  他们在痛苦我在快乐
Katrina: They're suffering, I'm enjoying.
Shure:  都多大了还还期中考试呢
Shure: How old are they to still have midterms?
Katrina:  我是一个爱学习的乖宝宝
Katrina: I'm a good student who loves studying.
Shure:  你是一个爱学习的人
Shure: You're a person who loves studying.
Katrina:  哈哈哈气死我了
Katrina: Hahaha, you're killing me.
Shure:  我是一个爱学习的人
Shure: I'm a person who loves studying.
Katrina:  我是一个爱学习的乖宝
Katrina: I'm a good student who loves studying.
Katrina:  整点music
Katrina: Let's play some music.
Shure:  什么什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: When are you going to clean the room?
Shure:  快扫房间
Shure: Hurry up and clean the room.
Shure:  然后把这个眼镜摘了
Shure: And take off these glasses.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  同意
Katrina: Agree.
Katrina:  你去跟老板介绍一下
Katrina: Go introduce yourself to the boss.
Katrina:  噢不对吹一下
Katrina: Oh no, just blow it.
Katrina:  听过这个卢广冢的歌吗
Katrina: Have you heard this song by Guangzhong Lu?
Shure: 谁
Shure: Who?
Katrina:  谁卢广冢
Katrina: Who is Guangzhong Lu?
Katrina:  哎哎我这平板那个音效特好
Katrina: Hey, hey, the sound effects on my tablet are great.
Katrina:  4个
Katrina: Four.
Katrina: 买来听歌
Katrina: Bought it to listen to music.
Katrina:  学习一点没干
Katrina: Haven't studied at all.
Katrina:  我靠跟音响一样
Katrina: Wow, it sounds just like a speaker.
Shure:  走去楼下听去
Shure: Let's go downstairs and listen.
Katrina:  楼下咋了
Katrina: What's downstairs?
Katrina:  PK一下你的音响跟我的平板吗
Katrina: Want to compare your speakers with my tablet?
Shure:  开玩笑那两个独立单元跟你这个比
Shure: Are you kidding? Those two separate units against your tablet?
Katrina:  哈哈哈我这一个这一个
Katrina: Hahaha, I have this one, this one.
Shure:  喝点嘛喝点嘛
Shure: Have a drink, have a drink.
Katrina:  又想套我话是不是哈哈哈
Katrina: Are you trying to get something out of me again? Hahaha.
Shure:  喝点喝点来来来
Shure: Have a drink, come on, come on.
Katrina: 不
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  今天晚上还有东西要干呢
Katrina: I still have things to do tonight.
Shure:  我24号交毕设
Shure: I have to submit my thesis on the 24th.
Shure:  你几号交毕设
Shure: When do you submit yours?
Katrina:  你论文写完了吗
Katrina: Have you finished writing your paper?
Shure:  写差不多了
Shure: Almost done.
Katrina:  呀怎么切了呀给我
Katrina: Hey, why did you change it? Give it back to me.
Katrina:  这什么老歌
Katrina: What old song is this?
Katrina:  林志炫的
Katrina: It's by Terry Lin.
Katrina:  我要去把楼下那个to do list写一下
Katrina: I need to go downstairs and write that to-do list.
Shure:  to do list是吗
Shure: The to-do list, right?
Katrina:  明天
Katrina: For tomorrow.
Lucia: 我靠嘞
Lucia: Oh my god.
Katrina:  成为一个自带BGM的女生
Katrina: Becoming a girl with her own BGM.
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Katrina:  却又消失不见
Katrina: And then suddenly disappearing.
Katrina:  明天干什么呀
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Shure:  杨老板我们什么时候扫房间啊
Shure: Jake, when are we cleaning the room?
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Katrina:  我们
Katrina: We...
Katrina: 明天干什么
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake:明天
Jake: Tomorrow...
Shure:  扫房间扫房间扫房间
Shure: Clean the room, clean the room, clean the room.
Nicous: 这是哪一个
Nicous: Which one is this?
Katrina: 呃这个p001应该是
Katrina: Uh, this should be p001.
Jake: 收拾完就开始扫
Jake: Clean up and then start sweeping.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 然后那个交换礼物
Jake: And then exchange gifts.
Nicous: 谁这么有这个品味竟然听这首歌
Nicous: Who has such good taste to listen to this song?
Shure:  你告诉我这是什么我给你放
Shure: Tell me what it is, and I'll play it for you.
Katrina:  卢广仲的歌
Katrina: It's a song by Crowd Lu.
Katrina:  明天干啥嘞
Katrina: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake:明天干啥嘞
Jake: What are we doing tomorrow?
Jake: 明天室外吧
Jake: How about something outdoors tomorrow?
Shure:  我们明天去
Shure: We're going
Shure:  KTV吧
Shure: to KTV, right?
Jake:可拉倒吧
Jake: No way.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina:  这附近好像有一个最近的公园
Katrina: There's a park nearby.
Katrina:  是两三公里
Katrina: It's about two or three kilometers away.
Katrina:  你要去公园吗
Katrina: Do you want to go to the park?
Jake: 可以去采一采景拍拍东西
Jake: We can go to check out the scenery and take some photos.
Jake: 然后最后一天放
Jake: Then release the video on the last day.
Katrina:  什么最后一天放
Katrina: What do you mean by "release on the last day"?
Jake:放放放影片
Jake: Release, release the video.
Katrina:  最后一天放影片
Katrina: Release the video on the last day.
Jake: 对这个采采风吧
Jake: Yeah, we can capture some scenery.
Katrina:  就是明天户外是吧
Katrina: So, it's outdoors tomorrow, right?
Jake: 对明天户外
Jake: Yes, outdoors tomorrow.
Jake: 采采风
Jake: Capture some scenery.
Katrina:  笑呀笑
Katrina: Haha, laugh it off.
Jake: 明天主要是等快递啊
Jake: The main thing tomorrow is to wait for the deliveries.
Katrina:  啊快递有好多才今天下的
Katrina: Ah, we ordered a lot of stuff today.
Jake: 对明天
Jake: Yes, tomorrow
Jake: 明天等快递
Jake: we'll wait for the deliveries.
Jake: 在路上后天你们快递
Jake: They'll be on the way, and the day after tomorrow your deliveries
Jake: 到了才能再setup吧
Jake: will arrive, and then we can set up.
Katrina:  其实其实快递的集中应该是在后天到
Katrina: Actually, most of the deliveries should arrive the day after tomorrow.
Katrina: 比较多明天还好
Katrina: Tomorrow won't be too bad.
Katrina:  你买时钟了吗
Katrina: Did you buy a clock?
Choiszt: 这首歌叫啥
Choiszt: What's this song called?
Katrina:  我爱你卢广仲的对
Katrina: It's "I Love You" by Crowd Lu.
Katrina:  那明天就一个户外
Katrina: So, tomorrow it's just outdoor activities.
Katrina:  不允许这么宽泛的存在
Katrina: You can't just exist so broadly.
Katrina:  你们当时那个表呢
Katrina: Where's that watch you had?
Katrina:  太阳公公出来了
Katrina: The sun has come out.
Katrina:  你居然
Katrina: You actually...
Katrina:  好吧略胜一筹啊
Katrina: Okay, you slightly won.
Shure:  哈哈哈这叫略胜吗
Shure: Hahaha, you call that slightly won?
Shure:  哈哈哈碾压
Shure: Hahaha, it's a complete victory.
Jake: 什么呀
Jake: What?
Katrina:  他说我的那个平板音响跟他的那个
Katrina: He said my flat speaker is a bit better than his.
Jake: 哦哦哦略胜一筹
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, just a little bit better.
Katrina:  开外挂
Katrina: Using cheats.
Katrina:  哦哦明天可以压一下花
Katrina: Oh, oh, we can press flowers tomorrow.
Katrina:  我爱你你知不知道
Katrina: I love you, do you know that?
Katrina:  曾经在我眼前
Katrina: Once in front of my eyes,
Katrina:  却又消失不见
Katrina: but then disappeared.
Katrina:  这是今天的第六遍
Katrina: This is the sixth time today.
Katrina: 电影里的配乐好像
Katrina: The soundtrack in the movie seems...
Katrina:  一下猥琐了起来
Katrina: to suddenly become sleazy.
Katrina:  美纹纸
Katrina: Masking tape.
Katrina:  对我笑呀笑
Katrina: Smile at me, smile.
Katrina:  我爱你你知不知道
Katrina: I love you, do you know that?
Tasha: 曾经在我眼前却又消失不见
Tasha: Once in front of my eyes but then disappeared.
Katrina:  这是今天的第六遍
Katrina: This is the sixth time today.
Katrina:  电影里的文乐好像你
Katrina: The soundtrack in the movie seems like you.
Shure:  好好久没喝这么多了
Shure: Wow, it's been a long time since I drank this much.
Katrina: 其实可以挑战一个高难度这样的
Katrina: Actually, we can try a higher difficulty.
Shure: 我来画这个来
Shure: I'll draw this one.
Katrina:  刚好我们在听音乐
Katrina: Since we're listening to music,
Katrina:  你画一个
Katrina: you draw one.
Katrina:  听音乐的小狗
Katrina: Draw a dog listening to music.
Shure: 看我的造化钟神秀阴阳割昏晓
Shure: Look at my masterpiece, splitting day and night.
Nicous: 我不明白
Nicous: I don't understand.
Katrina: 哎咋啦
Katrina: Hey, what's up?
Nicous: 这个为什么是bo01
Nicous: Why is this bo01?
Katrina:  boa01会不会是美版的型号
Katrina: Could boa01 be the American model?
Nicous: 然后我现在连得物都找不到了
Nicous: And now I can't even find it on the app.
Katrina:  你有小红书吗
Katrina: Do you have Xiaohongshu?
Nicous: 有
Nicous: Yes.
Katrina:  我搜一下啊
Katrina: Let me search it.
Katrina: 兰蔻bo01是啥
Katrina: What is Lancôme bo01?
Katrina:  bo01
Katrina: bo01
Katrina: 哦第二代
Katrina: Oh, it's the second generation.
Katrina: 怎么老更新啊
Katrina: Why do they keep updating?
Katrina:  DO00
Katrina: DO00
Katrina:  必须要注意
Katrina: Must pay attention.
Katrina:  哎有点水平啊
Katrina: Hey, there's some skill here.
Katrina:  我承认我承认
Katrina: I admit it, I admit it.
Katrina:  C01跟BO01差不多噻
Katrina: C01 and BO01 are about the same, right?
Katrina:  你能看出这是差别吗
Katrina: Can you tell the difference?
Katrina:  B O 01 P O 01跟P01
Katrina: B O 01, P O 01 and P01.
Katrina:  B O 01和P O 01其实应该都差不多吧
Katrina: B O 01 and P O 01 should be almost the same, right?
Katrina:  其实应该都差不多吧
Katrina: They should be almost the same, right?
Shure: 这个更粉一点
Shure: This one's a bit more pink.
Katrina: 哪个这个p01好像是
Katrina: Which one? This P01, right?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  怎么你能看出来了
Shure: How can you tell?
Katrina:  这得上脸我不知道他女朋友粉调还是黄调
Katrina: You have to try it on the face. I don't know if his girlfriend has a pink or yellow undertone.
Nicous:  maybe黄调
Nicous: Maybe yellow undertone.
Nicous:  所以其实不一样的嘛
Nicous: So, they are actually different, right?
Katrina:  这其实其实差不多了
Katrina: They are actually almost the same.
Katrina:  P u 0能搜到吗搜不到
Katrina: Can you find P U 0? No, you can't.
Lucia: 现在现在洗洁精好像在楼下是吧
Lucia: Now, the dish soap is downstairs, right?
Lucia:就这个锅他
Lucia: It's this pot.
Katrina: 那就是新款感觉b开头
Katrina: So, it's a new model, starting with B.
Nicous:  没有bo01啊卧槽
Nicous: There's no B O 01, damn.
Katrina:  那应该是是国外的那种
Katrina: It must be an overseas model.
Katrina:  基本上所有人都用的是P01
Katrina: Almost everyone uses P01.
Katrina:  就是正常的基数
Katrina: It's the normal base.
Katrina:  对你直接问
Katrina: Yeah, just ask.
Katrina:  大二是吧
Katrina: Sophomore year, right?
Katrina:  大二的时候我也刚刚学化妆
Katrina: I just started learning makeup in my sophomore year.
Katrina:  牛牛死了
Katrina: Niu Niu died.
Katrina:  这这事如果想让他上一个level
Katrina: If you want to take it to another level...
Katrina:  你知道应该加什么吗
Katrina: Do you know what to add?
Shure: 加什么眉毛
Shure: Add what? Eyebrows?
Katrina:  加一个他听的应该是RMP
Katrina: Add something, he should be listening to RMP.
Katrina:  哈哈哈这个and怎么写
Katrina: Haha, how do you write "and"?
Shure:  什么and啊
Shure: What "and"?
Shure:  我教你and怎么写啊啊
Shure: Do you want me to teach you how to write "and"?
Katrina:  啊sorry啊sorry
Katrina: Ah, sorry, sorry.
Katrina:  啊有点那个
Katrina: I'm a bit...
Katrina:  才疏学浅
Katrina: Not well-versed.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Katrina:  高级了
Katrina: It's advanced.
Jake:可以
Jake: It's good.
Shure:  可以吧
Shure: It's good, right?
Katrina:  一下高级了起来哎
Katrina: Suddenly, it feels more advanced.
Jake: 压花要压多久
Jake: How long do you need to press the pattern?
Shure:  半小时
Shure: Half an hour.
Katrina:  什么东西
Katrina: What?
Jake: 压花要压多久
Jake: How long should we press the flowers?
Jake: 压花
Jake: Press the flowers.
Katrina: 压花压花要压两天
Katrina: Pressing the flowers takes two days.
Katrina:  没有没有
Katrina: No, no.
Katrina:  你做了然后再放那放两天
Katrina: You do it and then leave it for two days.
Jake: 就是明天得压
Jake: So we need to press it tomorrow.
Jake: 明天压半小时
Jake: Press it for half an hour tomorrow.
Jake: 然后放那放两天是吗
Jake: And then leave it for two days, right?
Katrina:  压花随时随地可以压
Katrina: You can press the flowers anytime.
Katrina:  我就是手上闲了我就可以压
Katrina: Whenever I have free time, I can do it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  就把它摘下来放那就行了
Katrina: Just pick them and leave them there, it's fine.
Jake: 好那就
Jake: Alright then.
Katrina: 这就是我自己弄着玩的啊
Katrina: This is just something I do for fun.
Katrina:  给自己找点事做
Katrina: To keep myself busy.
Katrina:  其实就是把他撕下来就行
Katrina: Basically, just tear it off and that's it.
Katrina: 现在要去扫房间吗
Katrina: Do we need to clean the room now?
Jake:扫一遍就是边扫
Jake: Sweep it once, just sweep.
Jake:扫的话
Jake: If you sweep...
Jake: 那你们得躲着我
Jake: Then you guys need to avoid me.
Katrina: 就不进去呗
Katrina: So we shouldn't go in, right?
Jake: 对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake: 全导完
Jake: All done.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 我现在要扫
Jake: I'm going to sweep now.
Katrina:  哎这好看
Katrina: Oh, this looks nice.
Jake: 然后我不能扫到人
Jake: And I can't sweep near people.
Jake: 看到我就要躲
Jake: If you see me, you need to avoid me.
Katrina:  那我们待一楼呗
Katrina: Then we'll stay on the first floor.
Katrina:  你先去扫二楼可以
Katrina: You can sweep the second floor first.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Katrina:  是那天扫我们人体的那个机器吗
Katrina: Are you using the machine we used to scan our bodies the other day?
Jake: 不是就是iPhone
Jake: No, just the iPhone.
Katrina:  哦好
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Shure:  先去吧
Shure: Let's go first.
Katrina:  哇世界地球日的这个
Katrina: Wow, this Earth Day thing.
Jake: 然后你们可能在下面聊聊
Jake: And then you guys can chat downstairs.
Jake: 那什么
Jake: Like...
Katrina: 明天计划
Katrina: Tomorrow's plan?
Jake: 对明天在户外
Jake: Yes, it's outdoors tomorrow.
Jake: 原来是可以
Jake: Originally, it was possible.
Jake: 就是最后世界地球日
Jake: It's the last Earth Day.
Jake: 投影上面放点
Jake: Show some stuff on the projector.
Jake: 你们
Jake: You guys...
Katrina: 徒手画圆来徒手画圆
Katrina: Draw circles freehand, draw circles freehand.
Katrina:  画这地球
Katrina: Draw the Earth.
Jake: 秀点照片影片什么的
Jake: Show some photos, videos, whatever.
Jake: 在外边对
Jake: Outside, yeah.
Katrina:  哦那就是说我们要拍照是不是
Katrina: Oh, so we need to take pictures, right?
Jake: 采风就是采风
Jake: It's about gathering material, yeah.
Jake: 然后最好有个剧本
Jake: And it would be best to have a script.
Katrina: 剧本
Katrina: A script?
Jake: 但是很难
Jake: But it's difficult.
Jake: 所以就随便拍拍得了
Jake: So just shoot casually.
Katrina: 好像有我数学老师那感觉
Katrina: Feels like my math teacher.
Katrina: 我数学老师当时那个叫什么
Katrina: My math teacher used to, what's it called...
Katrina:  几何那边就这样画圆
Katrina: Draw circles in geometry like this.
Shure: 看我画的这个地球
Shure: Check out the Earth I drew.
Katrina:  这是什么呀
Katrina: What is this?
Katrina:  哎我发现你随便画画的
Katrina: Hey, I noticed your random doodles...
Katrina:  比我的那种有感觉比较活
Katrina: Have more feel, seem more alive than mine.
Shure:  所有的艺术都是通过一个灵性的方式来表现的
Shure: All art is expressed through a spiritual approach.
Shure: 千万不要把他搞死了
Shure: Never kill that spirit.
Katrina:  是是非非无法议论
Katrina: Right and wrong, can't discuss it.
Katrina:  I love yu
Katrina: I love you.
Katrina:  你很快乐
Katrina: You are very happy.
Katrina:  你最认真的心
Katrina: Your most sincere heart.
Katrina:  爱变得简单
Katrina: Makes love simple.
Katrina:  爱你
Katrina: Love you.
Katrina:  I love yu
Katrina: I love you.
Katrina:  一直的爱你
Katrina: Always love you.
Katrina:  I love yu
Katrina: I love you.
Nicous:  我照了开始那毕业照
Nicous: I took the graduation photos at the beginning.
Nicous:  这个这个就是这个吗
Nicous: This, this is it, right?
Nicous:  哦不是
Nicous: Oh, no.
Katrina: 不是这是睫毛膏
Katrina: No, that's mascara.
Katrina:  那是睫毛打底
Katrina: That's mascara base.
Nicous:  这个
Nicous: This
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina:  嗯拿棕色吧其实差
Katrina: Hmm, take the brown one, it's actually almost the same.
Katrina:  别不大用在眼睛上
Katrina: Don't use it too much on the eyes.
Katrina:  这没有颜色
Katrina: This one has no color.
Katrina:  这这无所谓
Katrina: This, this doesn't matter.
Katrina:  睫毛膏棕色黑色都行
Katrina: Mascara, brown or black is fine.
Katrina:  看女朋友
Katrina: Depends on your girlfriend.
Katrina:  如果想化浓一点的妆就用黑色
Katrina: If she wants a heavier makeup, use black.
Katrina:  可以都买棕色
Katrina: You can buy both in brown.
Katrina:  我手机在哪
Katrina: Where is my phone?
Tasha: 既然大家都是研究生了
Tasha: Since we're all grad students,
Tasha: 那我们就玩一些
Tasha: Let's play something,
Tasha: 飞花令
Tasha: Fei Hua Ling.
Lucia: 哦还可以
Lucia: Oh, that's fine.
Katrina:  我们开始扫了吗
Katrina: Have we started cleaning?
Jake: 对可以扫
Jake: Yes, you can start cleaning.
Jake: 是刚刚说什么研究生
Jake: What did you just say about grad students?
Lucia: 飞花令
Lucia: Fei Hua Ling.
Katrina:  可以扫我房间
Katrina: You can clean my room.
Tasha: 你会玩吗
Tasha: Do you know how to play?
Jake: 害怕
Jake: Scared.
Katrina:  什么飞花令
Katrina: What is Fei Hua Ling?
Katrina:  你说什么
Katrina: What did you say?
Katrina:  明天的游戏吗
Katrina: Tomorrow's game?
Lucia: 明天的游戏
Lucia: Tomorrow's game.
Jake: 对明天再再琢磨整点啥
Jake: Yes, we’ll figure out something for tomorrow.
Katrina:  哦我下去搜一下
Katrina: Oh, I'll go look it up.
Lucia: 用古诗词飞吗
Lucia: Using ancient poems?
Lucia: 还是飞什么别的东西
Lucia: Or something else?
Katrina:  古诗词我不行
Katrina: I'm not good with ancient poems.
Tasha: 不然用什么飞
Tasha: Then what else could we use?
Katrina: 第一个就死了
Katrina: I'd be out in the first round.
Katrina: 第一轮就死
Katrina: Out in the first round.
Katrina: 可以先扫呗
Katrina: Can we start cleaning?
Katrina:  我的房间已经收拾好了
Katrina: My room is already tidy.
Lucia: 比如不出来
Lucia: For example, not coming out.
Lucia: 哈哈啊
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 比如不出来
Lucia: For example, not coming out.
Katrina: 我看一下我们去那个地方
Katrina: Let me check if we are going to that place.
Tasha: 我就想问问扩展到哪些领域了
Tasha: I just want to ask, what fields have we expanded to?
Katrina:  忘了是怎么开始
Katrina: I forgot how we started.
Katrina:  看一下明天去哪个地方
Katrina: Let's see where we're going tomorrow.
Katrina: 我必须要看一下
Katrina: I really need to check.
Shure:  呵j人
Shure: Huh, really?
Shure:  就是要看一下明天去哪个地方是吧
Shure: You mean you need to check where we're going tomorrow, right?
Katrina:  对呀不然明天再决定去哪个地方的时候
Katrina: Yeah, otherwise, we'll waste another half an hour deciding where to go.
Katrina:  又会耽误半个小时在那决定
Katrina: It always takes forever to decide.
Shure: 随机去哪个地方就好了
Shure: Let's just go somewhere randomly.
Katrina: 得去公园吧
Katrina: We should go to the park.
Katrina:  咱这叫
Katrina: This is called...
Shure: 我们去环球
Shure: Let's go to Universal.
Katrina:  什么时候买新衣服啊
Katrina: When are we buying new clothes?
Katrina:  我跟我舍友说话
Katrina: I was talking to my roommate.
Katrina:  他们背着我逛街去了
Katrina: They went shopping without me.
Katrina:  来
Katrina: Come on.
Katrina:  我来教你
Katrina: I'll teach you.
Nicous:  这是买第三代这个
Nicous: This is the third-generation one, right?
Katrina: 嗯其实嗯
Katrina: Yeah, actually, um...
Katrina: 买对买这种细的
Katrina: Buy the thinner one.
Nicous:  不为什么这49这个90啊
Nicous: Why is this one 49, and this one 90?
Katrina:  本来就这样啊
Katrina: That's just how it is.
Katrina:  得物会贵一点
Katrina: Things are a bit more expensive on Dewu.
Katrina:  然后你那个还要加税费呢
Katrina: Plus, you have to pay taxes on top of that.
Nicous: 这个是吧
Nicous: This one, right?
Katrina:  对应该是还要加几块钱税费的十几块钱税费差不多60
Katrina: Yeah, you probably have to add a few dollars for taxes, about 60 in total.
Katrina:  本来代购就便宜
Katrina: Buying through agents is cheaper.
Katrina:  因为那个得物他要收手续费
Katrina: Because Dewu charges a service fee.
Katrina:  好男人
Katrina: Good man.
Jake: 啥呀这是
Jake: What's this?
Katrina:  给他女朋友买礼物挑的头疼
Katrina: He's having a hard time picking a gift for his girlfriend.
Jake: 你你怎么了
Jake: What's up with you?
Jake: 你你女朋友怎么了
Jake: What's up with your girlfriend?
Katrina:  没怎么
Katrina: Nothing.
Katrina:  就是一个平板
Katrina: Just a tablet.
Katrina:  就是一个开心
Katrina: Just to make her happy.
Jake:我要我要开扫了
Jake: I need to start sweeping.
Jake: 要不我先扫下面
Jake: Maybe I'll sweep downstairs first.
Shure: 快扫快扫
Shure: Go ahead, sweep quickly.
Jake: 上去吧
Jake: Let's go upstairs.
Shure: 为什么叫上去
Shure: Why go up there?
Jake:你们你们得上去
Jake: You guys, you need to go up there.
Jake: 下面那是空的啊
Jake: The bottom is empty, you know.
Shure:  好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Choiszt:  需要人手吗
Choiszt: Do you need manpower?
Jake: 这个不需要人手
Jake: No, we don't need manpower for this.
Shure:  不需要人是空的需要你没有
Shure: We don't need people, it's empty, you get it?
Shure: 你懂吗
Shure: Do you understand?
Shure: 向右转
Shure: Turn right.
Shure: 齐步走
Shure: March forward.
Katrina: 一二一
Katrina: One, two, one.
Katrina: 这是灯吗
Katrina: Is this a light?
Katrina:  居然不扫我的房间我房间早收拾好了
Katrina: You didn't clean my room, my room has been tidied up already.
Shure:  立定
Shure: Halt.
Katrina:  坐
Katrina: Sit.
Katrina:  爽啊这生活过100年
Katrina: Ah, this life is so enjoyable, I could live 100 years.
Lucia: 哎别我捏着捏着充电宝给他捏
Lucia: Hey, don't, I'm holding the power bank for him.
Alice: 算了给他弄弄掉吧
Alice: Forget it, just let it drop.
Shure:  真他妈爽
Shure: Damn, this feels great.
Shure:  我充电宝把这个榨干了已经
Shure: My power bank is completely drained already.
Shure:  期待着明天
Shure: Looking forward to tomorrow.
Lucia: 那我就先征用这个充电宝好了
Lucia: Then I'll just use this power bank for now.
Lucia: 我看一眼我那个还有多少电去拔线
Lucia: Let me check how much power is left, I'll unplug it.
Katrina: 通州区
Katrina: Tongzhou District.
Shure:  现在就在通州
Shure: We're in Tongzhou now.
Katrina:  咱是通州是吧我看看
Katrina: We're in Tongzhou, right? Let me check.
Katrina:  通州攻略哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Tongzhou guide, hahaha.
Katrina: 一天玩遍通州
Katrina: One day to explore all of Tongzhou.
Shure:  然后一搜全是环球影城
Shure: And if you search, it's all Universal Studios.
Shure:  我跟你讲
Shure: I'm telling you.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: You crack me up.
Katrina:  北京通州好玩的地方
Katrina: Fun places in Beijing Tongzhou.
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my gosh.
Jake:就是一会的扫描活动都在吗
Jake: So is everyone ready for the scanning activity later?
Jake: OK一会的扫描活动就是我在下面扫
Jake: Okay, for the scanning activity later, I'll be scanning downstairs.
Jake: 然后我下面扫完之后
Jake: After I'm done scanning downstairs,
Jake: 呃我会躲在一个房间里面
Jake: Uh, I'll be hiding in a room.
Katrina:  然后我们去找你
Katrina: And then we go find you.
Jake: 然后我为了不扫到人
Jake: And so I don't scan anyone.
Jake: 所以说我会在里面待着
Jake: So I'll be staying inside.
Jake: 然后我让刘帅下来叫你们
Jake: And then I'll have Choiszt come down to call you guys.
Jake: 然后但是我不能扫到你们对吧
Jake: But I can't catch sight of you, right?
Jake: 嗯所以说你们也要躲在一个房间里面
Jake: So you guys need to hide in a room too.
Jake: 就你们得躲在就你们就躲在
Jake: You guys should hide in, just hide in...
Jake: 你们就在你们就室外吧
Jake: You guys should stay outside.
Jake: 好吧好对
Jake: Alright, okay.
Choiszt: 一楼扫完了他们不都去一楼都可以去一楼
Choiszt: Once they finish sweeping the first floor, everyone can go to the first floor.
Jake: 就是我上楼的时候不能扫到人
Jake: When I go upstairs, I can't see anyone.
Jake: 我上楼的时候你们在
Jake: When I'm going upstairs, you guys...
Jake: 对对对对嗯
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, exactly.
Katrina:  行
Katrina: Got it.
Jake: 然后你们在这就聊一聊明天的安排吧
Jake: Then you guys can discuss tomorrow's plans here.
Katrina:  嗯那你就躲在一个
Katrina: Hmm, so you hide in a...
Choiszt: 反正我叫他们下去他们就下去藏好
Choiszt: Anyway, I'll call them down, and they'll hide.
Jake: 对你们就你们
Jake: Yes, you guys...
Katrina: 到外面去哦OK
Katrina: Go outside, okay.
Jake: 你们也可以
Jake: You guys can...
Jake: 现在在外边都都行
Jake: Now it's fine to be outside.
Jake: 总之就是我不能扫到人
Jake: The main thing is I can't see anyone.
Jake: 你们聊一聊啊
Jake: You guys chat.
Jake: 明天安排多多
Jake: Talk more about tomorrow's plans.
Jake: 多交流多交流
Jake: Communicate more.
Katrina:  西海子公园
Katrina: Xihai Park.
Jake: 多交流
Jake: Communicate more.
Jake: 反正明天大概是就是就是在户外
Jake: Anyway, tomorrow is basically outdoors.
Katrina: 我靠10km
Katrina: Wow, 10km.
Katrina:  通州这么大
Katrina: Tongzhou is so big.
Jake: 多说话啊多说话
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Nicous: 多说话那么简单我就一直跟你说
Nicous: Talking is easy, I'll just keep talking to you.
Katrina: 来呀
Katrina: Come on.
Shure:  多交流的方式是什么
Shure: What's the way to communicate more?
Shure:  多喝酒就多
Shure: Drink more and...
Shure:  交流了哈哈
Shure: Communicate more, haha.
Katrina:  浓密款
Katrina: Dense style.
Lucia: 边喝边唠嗑啊
Lucia: Drinking and chatting.
Lucia: 那咱整两盅
Lucia: Let's have a couple of drinks.
Katrina: 浓密延长其实都差不多了
Katrina: Dense and extended are pretty much the same.
Katrina:  真的没有那么大区别的
Katrina: There's not much difference really.
Katrina: 而且我估计你女朋友也不是很懂就截给你了
Katrina: And I bet your girlfriend doesn't really know, just cut it for you.
Katrina: 只是告诉你这个牌子而已KISSME确实是一个比较
Katrina: Just telling you about this brand, KISSME, it's quite...
Lucia: 啥呀这是啥
Lucia: What? What is it?
Shure:  其实就是
Shure: It's actually...
Shure:  刚才把你的橙汁换成了葡萄汁
Shure: I just swapped your orange juice with grape juice.
Shure:  他基本就是只喝了一口而已
Shure: He basically just took one sip.
Katrina:  他说吗
Katrina: Did he say that?
Nicous:  不是不是你看他妈的这什么场所
Nicous: No, no, look at this place, damn it.
Katrina:  一个是浓密款一个是
Katrina: One is for volume, and one is...
Katrina:  一个是浓密款一个纤长
Katrina: One is for volume, and one is for length.
Katrina:  纤长浓密浓巧三个
Katrina: Length, volume, and curl, three types.
Katrina:  种类但是一般买的是纤长或者浓密
Katrina: But generally, people buy either lengthening or volumizing.
Lucia: 你这个屏幕好酷啊
Lucia: Your screen is so cool.
Lucia: 是像素哎
Lucia: It's pixelated, huh?
Tasha: 你看点他就会有羊然后你把羊给拖过来
Tasha: If you click on it, there will be sheep, and then you drag the sheep over.
Katrina: 运河公园西海子公园搜一下
Katrina: Search for Canal Park or Xihai Park.
Katrina:  还是去公园吧
Katrina: Let's go to the park.
Katrina:  运河公园5.5公里那还行
Katrina: Canal Park is 5.5 kilometers away, that's okay.
Lucia: 那这些羊如果你很长时间不管他他会消失吗
Lucia: If you don't take care of these sheep for a long time, will they disappear?
Tasha: 不会
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 那你不断的点岂不是就会有很多很多的羊
Lucia: So if you keep clicking, won't you have lots and lots of sheep?
Tasha: 对然后可以跳到水里面
Tasha: Yes, and then they can jump into the water.
Nicous:  不行啦我有点破防了
Nicous: No way, I'm getting a bit overwhelmed.
Nicous: 我觉得你那个什么SB前男友买错是有道理的
Nicous: I think your stupid ex-boyfriend had a reason for buying the wrong one.
Katrina:  我把那个系列跟色号都告诉他了口红
Katrina: I told him the series and the shade for the lipstick.
Choiszt: 还有你的iPad
Choiszt: And your iPad.
Katrina: 噢噢
Katrina: Oh, oh.
Nicous: 口红都能买错确实太SB了他妈不就是一个数字嘛
Nicous: How could he mess up with lipstick? It's just a number, damn it.
Choiszt: 包括那边那个什么遥控器啥的拿一下
Choiszt: Also, grab that remote control over there.
Katrina: 不想多说
Katrina: I don't want to talk about it.
Nicous:  三代浓密黑色
Nicous: Third generation, black volume.
Choiszt: 还有那个沙发上的东西也收一下
Choiszt: And pick up the stuff on the couch too.
Nicous: 靠这是中文
Nicous: Damn, this is in Chinese.
Katrina:  你特别像那北京大爷
Katrina: You really look like an old Beijing man.
Katrina:  就是听别人在坐在那种相亲公园
Katrina: Listening to people in a matchmaking park.
Katrina:  听别人讲然后开始点评
Katrina: Listening to others and then commenting.
Shure:  没有我只是觉得
Shure: No, I just think...
Katrina:  没事我已经习惯了
Katrina: It's okay, I'm used to it.
Katrina:  怎么吐槽我前男友都无所谓
Katrina: I don't mind you criticizing my ex-boyfriend.
Lucia: 藏靠垫后面吧
Lucia: Hide it behind the cushion.
Katrina:  主要是
Katrina: The main thing is...
Katrina:  当然是他先删的我这一点让我很不爽
Katrina: Of course, he deleted me first, and that really pissed me off.
Katrina: 他先把我拉黑了
Katrina: He blocked me first.
Shure: 你再把他加回去
Shure: You should add him back.
Katrina: 全平台拉黑
Katrina: Blocked on all platforms.
Shure: 你再把他拉黑一遍
Shure: Then you block him again.
Katrina:  给我张纸弄我
Katrina: Give me a tissue.
Katrina: 裤子上了
Katrina: It's on my pants.
Katrina: 弄我鞋袜子上了
Katrina: It's on my shoes and socks too.
Katrina: 我加都不想加好吗
Katrina: I don't even want to add him back, okay?
Katrina: 他当时考完研还给我发短信呢
Katrina: He even texted me after his exams.
Katrina: 因为只有短信这一条路
Katrina: Because texting was the only option.
Nicous:  他还有脸发短信
Nicous: He still had the nerve to text.
Shure:  嗯就是
Shure: Yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  对对好搞笑你知道吗
Katrina: Yeah, it was so funny, you know?
Katrina:  搞笑的要命
Katrina: Hilarious.
Nicous:  还需要吗
Nicous: Do you still need it?
Katrina:  然后当时我就是属于呃
Katrina: At that time, I just didn't want to reply or block him.
Katrina:  就是不想回也不想拉黑
Katrina: I just didn't want to deal with it.
Nicous: 这两个的区别在于一个是中文一个是日文
Nicous: The difference between these two is one is in Chinese, the other in Japanese.
Katrina:  哦也有可能跟版本有关
Katrina: Oh, maybe it's a version thing.
Katrina:  但是这个牌子是日本牌子呀
Katrina: But this brand is Japanese.
Katrina: 差别不大啦你女朋友看不出来啦
Katrina: There's not much difference, your girlfriend won't notice.
Nicous: 直接得物买买不错
Nicous: Just buy it directly from Dewu.
Nicous: 直接得物买
Nicous: Just buy from Dewu.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 确实
Shure: For sure.
Katrina: 明天一天都在外面吗
Katrina: Will you be out all day tomorrow?
Katrina: 这还有佛教的东西
Katrina: There's some Buddhist stuff here.
Katrina:  这能带他们看吗
Katrina: Can we take them to see it?
Katrina: 西海子公园
Katrina: Xihai Park.
Katrina: 我还要去雍和宫还个愿呢
Katrina: I still need to go to Yonghe Temple to fulfill a vow.
Nicous: 我靠我觉得雍和宫一点都不准
Nicous: I think Yonghe Temple is not accurate at all.
Katrina: 啊我觉得特别准当时求财运
Katrina: Ah, I think it’s very accurate, I prayed for wealth.
Katrina: 财运还不错
Katrina: And it worked out well.
Shure:  你什么时候还愿的
Shure: When did you fulfill your vow?
Nicous: 我就没求财运
Nicous: I didn't pray for wealth.
Nicous: 我就应该去求财运
Nicous: I should have prayed for wealth.
Katrina: 当时我自己求的财运
Katrina: I prayed for wealth for myself.
Katrina: 给我两个好朋友求的考研上岸
Katrina: And prayed for my two good friends to pass their exams.
Katrina: 那两个都上岸了其他没上岸
Katrina: Those two passed, the others didn't.
Shure: 我妈我妈让我给我妹求的学业
Shure: My mom asked me to pray for my sister's studies.
Katrina: 学业应该也还行
Katrina: Her studies should be okay too.
Katrina:  我就带着这手串一直带
Katrina: I always wear this bracelet.
Katrina:  我开光了
Katrina: I got it blessed.
Katrina:  我当时还跪在第第一排
Katrina: I even knelt in the first row back then.
Nicous: 你是在雍和宫里面买的
Nicous: Did you buy it at Yonghe Temple?
Katrina:  嗯然后去开光
Katrina: Yeah, and then got it blessed.
Nicous: 380
Katrina: 280这个是280
Katrina: 280, this one is 280.
Nicous: 你知道当时我是怎么买的吗我去
Nicous: Do you know how I bought mine? I went to...
Nicous: 那个叫什么
Nicous: What's it called...
Nicous: 都不是我都不是在外面那边
Nicous: I didn't even buy it outside.
Shure:  外面那个什么法物流通处
Shure: That place outside, the Dharma supplies center.
Katrina:  就是法物流通处
Katrina: Yeah, the Dharma supplies center.
Nicous: 就那个最便宜那个地方
Nicous: The cheapest place.
Katrina:  啊叫叫叫叫叫
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, the marketplace selling bracelets.
Katrina:  就是那个卖手串的集市是吧
Katrina: You mean the marketplace selling bracelets, right?
Katrina: 叫什么来着三个字
Katrina: What's it called, three words...
Nicous: 对对对就里面好多卖眼镜的
Nicous: Yeah, yeah, the place with many glasses sellers.
Katrina: 北京
Katrina: Beijing.
Tasha: 潘家园
Tasha: Panjiayuan.
Katrina: 对对对太难受了你知道吗想不出来
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, it's so frustrating, I couldn't remember.
Shure:  潘家园跟北新桥离多远呢
Shure: How far is Panjiayuan from Beixinqiao?
Shure: 潘家园跟雍和宫离多远啊
Shure: How far is Panjiayuan from Yonghe Temple?
Nicous: 是远但是那边手串
Nicous: It's far, but the bracelets there...
Katrina: 手款式是一模一样的
Katrina: The styles are exactly the same.
Nicous: 三十块钱一个
Nicous: 30 yuan each.
Nicous: 然后买了
Nicous: And then I bought it.
Shure: 那他们能一样吗
Shure: Are they really the same?
Nicous: 一模一样
Nicous: Exactly the same.
Katrina: 据说应该是有正版和盗版的区别吧
Katrina: They say there's a difference between authentic and fake ones.
Katrina: 但是这个心诚则灵还是买正版吧
Katrina: But sincerity is what counts, better buy the authentic ones.
Katrina:  当时也没想到我
Katrina: Back then, I didn't even think...
Katrina:  还会来北京你知道吗
Katrina: I'd come to Beijing, you know?
Shure: 我需要充电我需要充电
Shure: I need to charge, I need to charge.
Katrina: 这充电宝没了吗
Katrina: Is the power bank out?
Shure:  哎这充电宝没了
Shure: Yeah, the power bank is out.
Lucia: 这个呢哎这好像不是
Lucia: How about this one? Oh, this one isn't...
Shure:  这是我我自个的充电宝
Shure: This is my own power bank.
Shure:  但是没有
Shure: But it's dead.
Lucia: 我是说这好像不是公共充电宝
Lucia: I mean, this doesn't seem like a public power bank.
Shure:  没有没有线了
Shure: There's no cable.
Shure:  我需要充电
Shure: I need to charge.
Lucia: 你是手机还是眼镜要充电了
Lucia: Is it your phone or glasses that need charging?
Shure:  手机手机手机
Shure: Phone, phone, phone.
Lucia: 我刚好像在这看到
Lucia: I think I saw one here just now.
Lucia: 有一个
Lucia: There's one.
Katrina: 看明天天气怎么样
Katrina: Let's check the weather for tomorrow.
Lucia: 不过这上面连不知道连着谁的线呢
Lucia: But I don't know whose cable this is.
Shure:  没事拔了
Shure: Just unplug it.
Shure:  给他拔下去了
Shure: Unplug it for them.
Lucia: 眼镜的线
Lucia: It's the glasses cable.
Katrina: 哇明天又是大晴天做好防晒
Katrina: Wow, it's going to be sunny again tomorrow, better prepare for the sun.
Shure:  只有周六周日是那个阴天
Shure: Only Saturday and Sunday will be cloudy.
Shure:  剩下咱们几个哦
Shure: The rest of us...
Katrina:  哇那我真运气好
Katrina: Wow, I'm really lucky then.
Katrina:  在这唉哦
Katrina: To be here, oh.
Lucia: 哦这个没电了
Lucia: Oh, this one is out of power.
Katrina:  明天28度呢我去
Katrina: It's going to be 28 degrees tomorrow, wow.
Lucia: 这不能征用了
Lucia: This can't be used.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina:  千鹤蟹路桥
Katrina: Qianhe Crab Road Bridge.
Shure: 你滚啊
Shure: Get lost.
Shure:  怎么会呢
Shure: How could that be?
Nicous:  嗯他说他就想要这个的
Nicous: Hmm, he said he just wants this one.
Nicous:  左边那是不是就是自然黑啊
Nicous: Is the one on the left naturally black?
Katrina:  对就是睫毛打底是先
Katrina: Yes, use the lash primer first.
Katrina: 用睫毛打底再用睫毛膏
Katrina: Use the lash primer and then the mascara.
Katrina: 她给你的意思就是睫毛打底买这个对
Katrina: What she meant is to buy this lash primer.
Katrina: 睫毛膏就买刚刚的那KISSME的
Katrina: And then buy the KISSME mascara.
Katrina:  攻略做的不错啊你女朋友
Katrina: Your girlfriend did a good job with the strategy.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Nicous: 那天晚上好像做了整整五个小时
Nicous: That night she seemed to have worked for a full five hours.
Shure:  刚那个吃饭的时候喝了一杯
Shure: She had a drink while eating just now.
Shure:  然后自己库库库喝
Shure: And then kept drinking.
Shure:  然后就喝
Nicous: 因为她也是纯j人
Nicous: Because she's also pure J.
Shure:  有一点点多吧
Shure: That might be a bit much.
Katrina:  我西海子公园评分4.8呢我去
Katrina: Wow, Xihai Park has a rating of 4.8, wow.
Shure:  等你呢等你呢好吧
Shure: Waiting for you, waiting for you, okay.
Katrina:  这时候可以拿我的风格了
Katrina: Now I can use my style.
Shure: 你好烦哦
Shure: You're so annoying.
Katrina:  这公园有那什么大摆锤什么的玩
Katrina: This park has that big pendulum ride and stuff.
Katrina:  这会得甩掉吧
Katrina: This might fling it off.
Katrina: 算了这个
Katrina: Forget about it.
Nicous: 我想问个问题代购他能发的很快吗还是发的很慢
Nicous: I want to ask, can the agent ship quickly, or is it slow?
Katrina:  基本发的还挺快的
Katrina: Usually, it's pretty quick.
Nicous: 他说写的什么
Nicous: What did he write?
Katrina:  你问客服
Katrina: Ask customer service.
Katrina:  问一下客服
Katrina: Just ask customer service.
Nicous:  他一般写预售都是不一定的是吧
Nicous: When they write 'pre-sale', it means it's uncertain, right?
Katrina: 应该是可以当天发
Katrina: It should be shipped the same day.
Katrina: 因为他们基本上都是专柜采购的
Katrina: Because they mostly purchase from the counters.
Katrina:  除非那个海淘会很慢
Katrina: Unless it's overseas, which can be slow.
Katrina:  西海子公园
Katrina: Xihai Park.
Katrina: 你们明天还来吗
Katrina: Are you coming tomorrow?
Nicous: 应该吧可能吧怎么说
Nicous: Maybe, probably, how should I say...
Katrina:  不怎么说只是问一下而已
Katrina: Just asking, no big deal.
Katrina:  他说就明天户外
Katrina: He said it's outdoor tomorrow.
Alice: 露西你见我的线了吗
Alice: Lucia, have you seen my thread?
Lucia: 呃在这里
Lucia: Uh, it's here.
Shure:  好困啊
Shure: I'm so sleepy.
Katrina:  我想洗澡呀
Katrina: I want to take a bath.
Shure: 洗过了
Shure: You already did.
Katrina:  就去西海子公园吧
Katrina: Let's just go to Xihai Park.
Shure:  唱吧你就
Shure: Just sing, will you?
Katrina:  通利弗尼亚
Katrina: Tonylifornia.
Katrina:  我真笑死
Katrina: I'm laughing so hard.
Alice: 你的手串
Alice: Your bracelet.
Katrina:  还可以划船呢
Katrina: You can even go boating.
Katrina:  北京艺术中心
Katrina: Beijing Art Center.
Katrina:  哎北京好适合带富士相机
Katrina: Hey, Beijing is perfect for a Fuji camera.
Shure:  是的我跟你讲
Shure: Yes, I'm telling you.
Tasha: 拍出来很好看
Tasha: The photos come out great.
Katrina:  哎我要搞电脑了
Katrina: Hey, I need to work on my computer.
Katrina:  这一两个地方差不多够了
Katrina: These one or two places should be enough.
Katrina:  因为等我们出门估计又2点多然后
Katrina: Because by the time we go out, it'll probably be past 2 PM.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Katrina:  这公园还挺漂亮
Katrina: This park is quite pretty.
Katrina:  OK就西海子公园
Katrina: OK, let's go to Xihai Park.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm
Katrina:  切更像大爷了哈
Katrina: Tsk, you're more like an old man now.
Shure:  你就拉着人家唱你这个你你唱的歌吧
Shure: Just pull someone over and sing that song of yours.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Okay?
Shure:  他们听过这歌吗
Shure: Have they heard this song before?